hablemos un poco sobre el elemento
fósforo hablemos de su importancia para
la vida y de cómo se lleva a cabo su
ciclo en los seres vivos entonces
hablemos del ciclo del fósforo y es muy
importante que sepamos que el fósforo es
un elemento muy reactivo por lo que
raramente se encuentra solo normalmente
lo encontramos en forma de fosfato que
es esta molécula donde el átomo
anaranjado corresponde al átomo de
fósforo y está unido a 4 oxígenos y al
menos como lo vemos aquí tiene una carga
de menos 3
así que generalmente puede formar en la
sesión y coss con otras cosas o uno de
los oxígenos puede formar un enlace
covalente o incluso podemos formar ácido
fosfórico en el que los oxígenos se unen
con hidrógenos pero bueno esta es la
forma general que encontramos
normalmente y el átomo que estoy
señalando es el átomo de fósforo pero a
todo esto se le llama
este es el fosfato y lo podemos
encontrar presente en macromoléculas muy
importantes en biología como por ejemplo
este es el adn y tanto el adn como el rn
tienen esqueletos de fosfato aquí
podemos verlo en los lados
ese es el esqueleto de nuestras
moléculas de adn y miren en el centro de
todos esos fosfatos tenemos el átomo de
fósforo y también por acá y lo mismo por
acá después
aquí tenemos atp en biología estudiamos
eso y es la fuente de poder es la moneda
de energía de los sistemas biológicos y
su nombre completo es adenosina
trifosfato pues tenemos tres grupos
fosfato aquí y cuando le quitamos uno de
estos grupos fosfato se pueden iniciar
reacciones como por ejemplo puede
cambiar la conformación de las enzimas
puede hacer todo tipo de cosas
interesantes
así que el fosfato es esencial para la
vida pues la vida como la conocemos
involucra al atp y al adn y a muchas
otras cosas en las que encontramos a los
fosfatos ahora el fosfato y
particularmente el fósforo es un poco
diferente del carbono o del nitrógeno y
no se encuentra en la atmósfera
normalmente no se encuentra como un gas
más bien el fosfato se encuentra en las
rocas lo podemos encontrar en rocas
fosfórica formadas a base de fosfato
también contienen otros elementos como
el cloro y hay muchos tipos de rocas
fosfórica pero cuando se encuentra en
forma de sedimento voy a dibujar el
suelo supongamos que en este suelo hay
fosfato y eso permite que las plantas
crezcan en este suelo esta es una planta
en crecimiento
esta es la planta de la que hablamos en
otro vídeo puede fijar el carbono de la
atmósfera usando la energía luminosa
pero su fosfato
viene del suelo el fosfato está aquí y
eso ayuda a que la planta crezca porque
necesita ese fosfato para su atp su adn
su adn y otras cosas más y generalmente
el fosfato se considera como un factor
limitante de la velocidad de crecimiento
de cosas como las plantas es por eso que
muchos fertilizantes contienen fósforo o
mejor dicho fosfatos e incluso nitrógeno
entonces la próxima vez que necesiten un
fertilizante o si es que están
fertilizando su jardín lean los
ingredientes y encontrarán el fosfato
porque ese puede ser el recurso escaso
es decir lo que limita el crecimiento de
la planta y tal vez me digan bueno yo
tengo atp y adn en mi cuerpo como
obtengo los fosfatos bueno los obtienen
comiendo plantas
eres tú comiendo una planta entonces la
planta está para acá y como podemos
formar un ciclo aquí bueno cuando
cualquiera de esta materia viva muere y
como lo mencioné en el vídeo anterior
voy a dibujar una planta muerta porque
un animal muerto sería un poco más
impactante entonces por ejemplo si una
planta muere y supongamos que está
enterrada ahí está nuestra planta muerta
bueno los fosfatos que había en esa
planta ahora regresan al suelo entonces
podemos ver esto como un ciclo y lo
mismo ocurrirá cuando ustedes mueran y
cuando yo muera si nos entierran los
fosfatos volverán al suelo pero también
existen otras formas en las que el
fosfato y el fósforo correspondiente es
reciclado vamos a verlo a gran escala
vamos a suponer que tenemos un río aquí
tenemos un río bueno un río pequeño a
comparación de la planta tan grande que
dibuje entonces el río puede tomar los
fosfatos del suelo y llevarlos al océano
y después esos fosfatos pueden ser
utilizados por la vida marina y cuando
la vida marina muere todo baja al fondo
del océano y en algún momento en el
futuro esos sedimentos en el océano son
empujados a la tierra y así una planta
puede crecer entonces podemos imaginar
todo tipo de cosas para estos ciclos y
cada vez estamos encontrando más y más
pues como seres humanos decimos oye si
el fosfato es el factor limitante para
el crecimiento de las plantas nosotros
necesitamos hacer crecer muchas plantas
para que podamos comer y bueno así fue
que empezaron a extraerlo y agregarlo al
suelo pero eso también permitió que
mucho de esto sea arrastrado por los
ríos y arroyo
con lo que en algún momento termina en
el océano y como veremos después esto
puede tener un impacto negativo para
nuestra biosfera